[Music]
a little more more life so he he'll come
in right he'll he'll get it and I have
to move with it so I kind of let him get
it and I make sure that I hit neutral
young so I don't want to be here you
feel that difference here you're trying
to do that hit the neutral so that it's
quick like that you guys see that okay
so same thing you don't have to be here
waiting but I I'm going to let kind of
get it and when he gets it end up in
that two on one there same thing boom
two on one okay let's try
shoulder here Wai w w w so he's already
moving I'm already Ang pay attention you
and you go me moving already angled you
see when he goes I'm already angling
woman minute easy peasy okay if if he
get if he gets it and he has the
anchored elbow that is I'm going to have
to do something
else as opposed to I still you got it I
already angle so pay go a little slower
so she can see look I already angled do
you see that that's not the
same uh collar tie as
this so moving this a little out of
range to pay attention here keep my head
here head move back you see the elbows
less anchored right and then I add my
angle
boom I'm off angle and then I add the
shoulder different just smaller you see
so all that is as we ha you get here
real quick okay I try it
again
no
no go back to St
not you
Chris no
no
shoulder lift your shoulder
up and then get the for non
contention hold the hold it hold it
shoulder up okay do understand CU I'm
not I'm not here trying to Grapple you
you this is just my starting point go in
so I'd be here probably trying to do
something you had to go around it you
see okay I'm not here like this okay so
I'd be here right boom trying to do this
kind of stuff and then you got in there
so my hands aren't down here with my
chin out there here like this he goes I
set it up okay try it
again can't turn your head away
can't give your back like that he has to
stay in front of
you just like
10 you can't turn your back in front of
him you you're going get
there go like this strong my back is my
back is TE you see that I I have to turn
behind you so the same thing here I
can't yeah get it I can't go like this
okay you have to go P me okay don't turn
your back in front of them go you are
like defending this stuff and he came
here and you're
like this you see that this don't let me
do
that it's not going to happen and then
he by the time I try that he's going to
Elbow me in the freaking face do you get
it it's it's the same thing as he comes
on that collar tie and I go like this
he's still coming in cuz you're doing
your little Karate Kid move you
see not it's not going to work you
understand so he he's he'd be aggressing
and he got that I have to get that move
that way okay let try it again
get your Center Low find your ground
path pay attention here's here's what
we've been demonstrating I'm not here
like this I'm in here like this and
okay so we're here like
this I'm not I'm not doing that stuff
okay that's a whole C at the beginning
remember what's he going to be doing
he's aggressing try to get the close
range so don't start M miles away like
you can just walk in okay try it again
get your hands up get your
up go slow do it
slow and resting
there then my head comes out
you're doing like something weird here
trying to get something I just don't
want your hand to follow my head so I
have to lift up my shoulder I roll my
hand out and my shoulder go over that's
all it is this hand here to catch
it all right you guys will keep working
on that okay all right so we go boom and
you're going to have
that arm like this in all
likelihood you can still put pressure on
that
arm this way okay that's all I'm going
to do so from the from the
movement I put pressure on that arm see
that you guys see that in other words
don't come here and just catch it around
boom pressure on the arm you can
push he's going to come up boom arm
comes up right he wants to get height
arm comes up you can
[Music]
kick P pressure arm comes up you have
your throws
here but put something
there around weight okay get there they
try Dynamic more circular
more circular circle circle circle
circle circle start circling when he
comes in there it
is
circle they're going to do the STA over
there Circle
so think about where you can apply
pressure on the elbow so if I go here on
this arm nothing but if I keep this
thing flat I'm on the I'm on this side
you
see okay don't let me break your arm
time okay one two here around go can you
feel that yes not not here like that yes
I don't want the joints to open so I
just keep it here and I drop my okay got
it okay try
it now uh we're here I get the pressure
I he's going to want to come up so let
him come up and that's where you have
the high angle okay this is we were
having problems with this right the
other day finding it it's a little
different in the beginning but the move
is exactly the same boom energy goes up
find
[Music]
it don't find his energy coming
up don't in other words you're he T try
to hold them down right when he comes up
that's where you follow it in you follow
H you has to go
up okay let's
try be ready not fast
okay one soft on the
elbow boom you come up I let you go I'm
letting I'm not here you go and then I
go I give you the space to take your
moov
[Music]
okay you see that so I'm not stopping
you um but I'm also not letting space
open per se right there's like just
enough that you can go okay all right
try to to the uh to the
Bice see he already did did his job he's
going to pull out of
that so as he
goes okay watch my watch my head watch
my head as he goes it's already
going he
goes okay inside hand try
better it's easy peasy okay it's easy
peasy when we get it
right
yes and we do put your hand right
here you do the other side do the other
side
that's where that hand goes and it's
already there it's already there don't
use your elbow use your shoulder and you
could already start catching it cuz it's
already off of you okay
boom good watch your balance
man you're uh going around you're going
here
okay but what's his balance
do okay so when you're like this it
goate
someone then you
[Music]
is he got his color tie and let's look
at it come closer see he's going to
Anchor his elbow so that he can't
control my penetration range and then
he's hooking on the back here then he
controls that range too you got it okay
so you have to deal with that anchored
elbow all right so he he got it I'm
going to just come up and grab my grab
my own C okay and even though I'm here I
can still move him you see you you can
still control him the same way you don't
have to go and take the other one like
does a lot I just come up and take this
one okay and as I move him so he's going
to try to pull and I'm ground vectory on
the front leg you see ground vectory on
the front leg done it okay I can't be
here you're going to going to get me
and I can't just be athletic cuz that's
where you can move me around and stuff
so I have to ground Vector right and
move him off the front
foot okay so we'll start static I'm
going here and let's just do a
progression so you're just going to have
them try to pull and you're on the front
foot you're just pulling into the front
foot next progression go ahead and just
move him off the front foot okay we'll
try that then we'll build
as he going the deeper he is into that
the harder this is going to be the
harder this is going to be okay so you
do the same thing on the mod you see
where I where I got it it's not it's not
as anchored okay so same on the pull and
find that center it's much easier to do
okay so get to there and you're doing
the
same you can do it on the
turn get him to move okay let's
try keep
so what what am I doing different from
Taylor you're moving your base yeah I'm
moving my base as supposed to doing like
that okay right okay try it again close
to your front
fo that's fo that's what I want I don't
want your
other I want this so I move can make
that fo you
see I have to move your front
foot okay
now he's going and I'm going to do the
same movement right same movement I'm
doing but in that movement I'm going to
pop
this this way and I'm going to go under
it then I'm here see that so yes yes I'm
moving in this way but as I'm moving
them that way I'm coming into that angle
there okay okay don't do one two throw
them this way as you're entering that
way okay try
it she goes
and right where she goes this is too
late right she go I'm already here okay
try it
again he's trying to Anchor right okay
so I'm going to
pop and go under
it okay then I make her
come the other
way she's going
right she's
going this is where I'm at this is all
I'm doing right she goes again that's it
she goes again that's it that's all I'm
doing right now okay try it
again he's doing his arm is coming
out and as his arm's coming out I have
to touch the back of
him got it okay throw a punch his arms
coming out and his arm comes out I have
to touch a part of him you got it so he
goes
and I hit him as he's hting me you
understand so he
goes that's not it so same thing here
boom that's not it you guys understand
as he g is how I'm doing the move in
okay try it again you can go as slow and
smooth as you want but you're looking
for that you're just following around
and pop popping it okay try it
again okay has to stay on inside your
Bas of support you can't have it like
this okay try to that's part of that
that athleticism that I'm not seeing
okay let's
go say start start thinking about what
what is this hand doing at this
point nothing nothing okay so once this
hand goes there it goes right to there
you guys are over here
boom and then you're doing this no just
like I want to hit here and I want to
hit here who throws his strip it it's
already moving right same exact thing so
we're here boom and it goes right to
there and I start pressing okay try it
again go that
way really go that
way you control what he's doing do you
understand yes so I get that when you
have his leg and you shove with him he's
going slly backwards no I stop he falls
not I get pulled off and bad mechanics
okay try it
[Music]
again come behind
him oh let's do this come behind him
you're right there okay so I don't want
to be like
this I I want to
ground do you understand so really push
Virginia
[Music]
r i I have to
ground do you understand so this angle
that you guys think is strong it's not
strong and it's really compromising your
posture at the end okay so try
again Chris question I was just going to
ask the exact same thing what do you
mean by back angle your back angle is
your your posterior chain activation
angle not it
okay if you have to go lower that's when
you go on your knee you keep that same
angle you're not going to be here so
you're not going to be here right okay
try to
[Music]